for me as an actor this was
predominantly pushing a narrative in uh
almost complete silence which was part
of the excitement about this journey for
me a lot of the time during the the the
rehearsal process we would work with all
the different departments during the day
and it would almost be like doing
theater during the day and it was like
live television for the last hour and a
half of magic light so we had to make
sure that certain nuances were captured
certain beats were captured certain
emotion moments were captured and what
they were able to do is capture
incredible intimacy with the characters
and then weave seamlessly around to an
unbelievable David lean style shot you
know it I I've never quite seen anything
cinematically like that and what they
achieve with the actors in This film and
uh in some of these shots I think is
quite groundbreaking in that respect
I've never seen a movie accomplish
that